what's going on guys this is rob and
this video is brought to you by starkid
industries now right now stark
industries is looking for someone to go
back in time with them now this is not a
joke right you'll be paid after
everything is all said and done once you
guys get back but your safety is not
guaranteed you're going to have to bring
your own weapons something to keep in
mind
stark industries has only ever done this
once before so if you're interested then
make sure you guys check out the link in
the description
having said that there's the meme going
around that toby maguire's spider-man is
the first mcu movie that's not 100 true
i mean i get his design to be a joke but
let's say that it is true if that's true
then x-men is actually the first mcu
movie here's the reason why i say that
deadpool exists in the marvel cinematic
universe now right he had the little
short where he crossed over with korg
from thor ragnarok and then kevin feige
and then we're also like yeah it's
deadpool 3. his story is going to
continue on we're not rebooting or
anything like that so if deadpool exists
in the mcu then we also know that james
mcavoy and those guys exist in the mcu
we know that from deadpool 2 because
they had a cameo in the second deadpool
movie james mcavoy being the guy who
played the younger professor xavier the
reason why i say that is because in
x-men days of future past patrick
stewart played the older professor
xavier which was made the actual future
timeline for james mcavoy and that
because patrick stewart appeared in the
first x-men movie
basically x-men from 2000 is in the mcu
now because of deadpool having said that
let's get into the leaks and rumors for
doctor strange 2. now as always whenever
we do this kind of thing i always tell
you guys take it with a grain of salt do
not take it as an absolute because these
leaks could be entirely wrong however
there have also been times where huge
plot leaks have been dumped on 4chan and
reddit and places like that and they all
turned out to be true so it can kind of
go either way having said that according
to these leaks there's some huge things
going on here they don't really address
the main point of the movie which is to
say all the things that go on from like
the beginning of the movie to the middle
of the movie it really just focuses on
the ending of the movie but what we
basically end up finding out is that
essentially wanda is responsible for the
collapse of everything like the
multiverse basically falling apart and
that what's actually happening here is
instead of universes like exploding or
being wiped from existence or something
like that they're actually converging
that they're all basically merging down
into what's being called the void now
this sounds a lot like battle world or
the far shore or blight spoke if any of
you guys are familiar with any other
kind of stuff if you don't know what
that is battle world when it originally
appeared in secret wars 1984 was when
the beyonder basically took chunks of
like places across the universe and then
just smashed them into a singular planet
in the secret war storyline by jonathan
hickman in 2015 battle world was
actually a world that was formed by dr
doom in an attempt to save what was left
of the multiverse by taking these
different portions of realities and
merging them all together into a
singular world so it was basically a
planet composed of different alternate
universes now blight spoke is something
that jonathan hickman created relatively
recently in the story's ten of swords
which came out of x-men and basically
blight spoke is like a big landfill for
dead realities essentially right
realities that have been destroyed or
those little fragments of them left they
all just kind of get dumped in that
place the far shore is essentially a
place beyond all of creation right that
is essentially the realm of the one
above all i wouldn't say it's any one of
these three things i would say it seems
like it's kind of a combination of them
right really more battle world than
anything else so does this mean that
it's setting up for secret wars i don't
know but the important thing here
is that at the end of this movie what
doctor strange does is he basically
forms his own avengers team to face off
against schuma gorath now i guess maybe
this also points to the idea that it
actually is gargantuas which i still
think is a stupid idea i don't care if
gargantos is like an agent of
shumogorath who appeared in the universe
but the important thing here is that
apparently shumogorath is like the main
bad guy in this movie he's the main foe
and doctor strange assembling a
multiversal avengers team is designed to
defeat schumer gorath and that's where
the cameos come into play so right off
the bat there are a few that we for the
most part suspect and i assume are
pretty much all but confirmed right so
like hugh jackman patrick stewart uh
charles xavier we've seen like leaks and
and stills and things along those lines
i think for the most part while we
haven't really seen an exact
confirmation the hugh jackman wolverine
is basically a shoe-in for like doctor
strange too i can't imagine why they
wouldn't have him there but the cameos
outside of those guys are crazy because
they're way more interesting so the
first one and one that i'm pretty sure a
lot of you guys are really suspecting
here is deadpool the last one is one you
guys are never gonna suspect but the
first one is deadpool right now it makes
the most sense that if if the marvel
cinematic universe wants to bring
deadpool in having him come through by
way of doctor strange could be a pretty
comedic thing right one of those things
where he's like i mean i'm not going
back to my universe that place sucks
right i mean i don't know if you ever
saw the fox movies but they blow balls i
want to stay here you guys know what
you're doing
something along those lines right but
regardless it could be a way for
deadpool to kind of segue back in to the
to the marvel cinematic universe itself
but regardless of how they choose to
treat deadpool it'd be a great way for
them to integrate him into the mcu
through the events of doctor strange it
makes the most logical sense now beyond
that another cameo that is leaked to
appear in doctor strange 2 is ian
mckellen's magneto now we have no idea
under what context he's going to be
there if i'm a betting man because the
marvel cinematic universe has borrowed
so heavily from jonathan hickman and the
various stories that he's written over
the years avengers new avengers infinity
all that kind of stuff even seemingly
secret wars from 2015
what we were probably going to be
getting is what we suspect that we're
getting which is an alternate reality
version of the illuminati right
basically this kind of secret group that
operates behind the scenes effectively
controlling what goes on around their
world in terms of like superhero antics
and things like that right the
illuminati is not trying to use power
and influence to conquer the world
they're not the hellfire club right or
they're not like the hand or anything
along those lines but it is still kind
of a cool little thing there right we
could see an alternate reality version
of them and it wouldn't make sense that
a lot of the rumors that are circulating
out there are saying that like baron
mordo is on that team that professor
xavier is on that team and that ian
mckellen's magneto could be on that team
as well whether he is or not we don't
really know it's just this leak that
he's apparently in the movie now there
are a couple other little things here
right apparently halle berry is supposed
to return as storm apparently eric bana
is supposed to return as the incredible
hulk that's where the limits of
credulity kind of started to get
stretched as far as i was concerned but
then they brought me back with the big
reveal and it was like damn i really
hope that's true right another person
that's supposed to be in this movie as
far as the leaks go anyway is james
marsden returning as cyclops or the guys
who don't remember him he played cyclops
in the original x-men movie i'll be
honest i always felt like he was kind of
an unsung hero of the fox x-men movies i
loved him as cyclops he was a great
cyclops i mean he was the only one that
we really got for any real measurable
amount of time but he was a great
version of that character i want to see
him come back i would love to see him
return but here are the two big
name drops right the two big reveals
who are supposed to be in the movie now
again i'm telling you guys
these are leaks
these are not facts
[Music]
even though i really want them to be
number one
supposedly toby mcguire is supposed to
show up again now he's not going to
actually appear in the movie it's more
gonna be like a voiceover that kind of a
thing and under what situation that is i
have no real clue but apparently it's
just supposed to be some kind of
disembodied thing i have no idea under
what context he's gonna appear here's
the important thing and and this may be
one of those things where as soon as you
guys hear this you guys are like man
right are you here and you're just like
yes right
supposedly
nicholas cage
is coming back
as ghost rider
not only is he coming back as a ghost
rider he's supposed to be absurdly
powerful like
table turning powerful like things are
popping off everybody's being defeated
and then here comes ghost rider to
literally save the day not only that
he's gonna name drop mephisto now here's
the thing man
i don't agree i haven't heard of this is
if this is like a thing that's
circulating around maybe it is maybe
some of you guys already know i have not
heard that and as soon as i heard that i
was like
please let it be true because let's be
honest with ourselves all right nicholas
cage's ghost rider was not that great
but nicholas cage as ghost rider was
amazing and i would love to see him in
the mcu but here's what i think is going
on right okay so here's an important
thing i imagine if you're watching this
one of the things you're probably gonna
ask yourself is okay that's cool and
everything are we going to see king
right was there anything to indicate
kane's going to show up in the movie i
don't think kang is going to show up in
this movie and the reason why is because
i don't think the events of loki have
happened yet or if they have they will
have happened towards the tail end of
this movie now i know you guys are
probably like okay that doesn't make any
sense like it's literally multiverse of
madness the multiverse came back at the
end of loki surely it's all going on
okay so here's the thing so i actually
did a whole bunch of digging around on
this right i did like a whole bunch of
research and all that kind of stuff
because even i found myself confused and
a lot of you guys probably realized that
in the videos that we made about loki i
admitted it multiple times i wasn't
really 100 sure what was going on
because even in loki they didn't do that
great of a job of explaining it like it
wasn't one of those things where you
walked away and you're like yes i have a
perfect understanding of what's going on
like literally just internet form after
internet form was just filled with like
okay so what the hell is going on with
the multiverse and how do we reconcile
the birth of the multiverse or the
return of the multiverse seemingly in
loki with like everything the ancient
one told doctor strange and like
everything going on in spiderman no way
home and like everything from avengers
end game right like how can doctor
strange see 14 million possibilities if
the multiverse doesn't exist okay so
here here just to kind of kind of
provide some context to this right so
the writer of loki came out recently and
said no the multiverse is there and the
multiverse has always been there that
the way it worked is that he who
remained had basically altered
everything in such a way to where when
the initial multiversal war took place
and you had like all those different
versions of hugh remains one of which
was like kane the conqueror or
presumably a bunch of king the conqueror
is right the council of kings and they
were like conquering different realities
but he who remains as we know from the
show had basically weaponized alias or i
think i don't remember how you pronounce
them anyway weaponized the giant smoke
monster right and then literally used it
to destroy entire realities and
essentially eliminate every universe out
there that would lead to the creation of
kang and then from there formed this
sacred timeline the sacred timeline is
in and of itself a multiverse it's just
a finite multiverse i mean in truth the
multiverse doesn't have to be infinite
for it to be a multiverse you could have
three universes and it could be a
multiverse we just largely associate a
multiverse with an infinite number of
universes because that's usually how
it's always depicted right like whenever
you look at comics or you look at any
kind of like fictional media or even
science itself the the multiverse is
usually depicted as like an infinite
number of universes so we just kind of
combine those two things say they're
synonymous and roll with it and so
seemingly what had happened is that he
who remains had basically eliminated
every possible alternate reality where
any event that could take place in that
universe would lead to the creation of
kang and only kept the universes that
would lead to his existence right so if
we were to take the events like
spider-man no way home right let's say
that spider-man no way home is timeline
zero right then we have timeline one and
timeline two in timeline one tom holland
becomes venom right and in timeline two
tom holland dies at the end of
spider-man no way home right now let's
say that in timeline one where he
becomes venom because for whatever
reason venom's that important that in
the 31st century nathaniel richards
chooses to become kang instead of
becoming he who remains that the tva
would step in and wipe that wipe that
universe from existence right they would
purge it but if in timeline two where
peter parker dies at the end of
spider-man no way home in the 31st
century nathaniel chooses to become he
who remains then nothing will happen
because it guarantees the existence of
he who remains and it never leads to the
creation of king the conqueror so if
that's the case then it would make sense
why it is that dr strange was able to
see 14 million possibilities because
there's 14 some odd million universes
out there it's just those 14 some odd
million universes all result in he who
remains instead of king the conqueror
now things are different right now it's
just totally unchecked multiverse
whatever everything's popping off
thought i'd add that in there to kind of
clarify i'm sorry if it feels like i'm
going off on a bit of a tangent but
using that concept you could easily say
that like the fox x-men universe now
that marvel studios owns it right that
the universe of like like tony maguire
spider-man the universe like andrew
garfield all that stuff that's one of
those 14 million some odd possibilities
universes whatever that exists out there
and that's just based on the events of
like avengers in game right that's not
accounting for any of the other possible
universes that exist out there where
like he who remains comes into existence
instead of kang so we're just kind of
using 14 million as a finite number
because that's the only number we've
ever really gotten in terms of like
alternate possibilities or alternate
realities right so we're just kind of
rolling with that but nonetheless right
that's how you can kind of make all this
work and just be like the events of loki
haven't happened yet right that that the
events of loki happen at like the end of
doctor strange right so like seemingly
when everything seems saved suddenly
it's just all these universes just
converging and smashing into each other
because like sylvia killed immortus he
remains whatever killed a mortise and
like now everything's popping off right
or like that's when kang shows up or
something along those lines right like
you know takes people out who knows who
cares but regardless i just want to kind
of throw that out there in any event
keep in mind these are leaks right these
are not an absolute thing so it's
entirely possible that all of this could
be wrong and i want to i want to make
sure that i make that clear none of this
could be true or all of it could be true
but let me know what you guys think down
in the comments section right which one
of these these things are true and and
if you could pick one person to appear
in the marvel cinematic universe who
would it be
who do you want to see more than anybody
else but with that being said guys we're
going to bring this to an end thank you
guys for watching and i will catch you
all later
peace